welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am Benjamin Dixon filling in for David
while he is away on vacation I want to
share an image on your screen take a
look at this this is an image a graph
that was made by the Washington Examiner
which is a right-wing rag but they're
citing data from a new Gallup poll that
just came out the states that bit
through only 51% of Americans think that
socialism would be bad for the US while
43% think that socialism would be good
for the US and 6% have no opinion now if
you look at the bottom corner you can
see they put up the data from 1942
because they want to scare you they want
you to see that America is going in
their own direction in 1942
40 percent thought that socialism would
be bad for the United States and only 25
percent thought that it would be
positive while 34 percent had no opinion
on the matter the question that the
Gallup poll interviewers asked was with
some form of socialism be a good thing
or a bad thing for the country as a
whole this you know socialism is is the
boogeyman the boogeyman of the right it
has been for some time and and of course
we can parse the difference between
socialism of communism
particularly democratic socialism our
social - or a social democracy versus
communism but this has been the the muse
of conservatives for time immemorial
they have engaged in the Red Scare and I
want to be sure about something the
picture that they if you don't mind put
in the picture back on the screen they
have this scary picture of Bernie
Sanders or Bernie Sanders looking you
know weird for lack of a better word and
then they have aoc laughing I want to
reassure the American people of
something or at least those of you who
are listening to this program Bernie
Sanders and Alexandria Acacio Cortes
they are not real socialists I don't
know we can get into that
can fallen to the like the no true
Scotsman kind of fallacy but I want to
assure you there are people way further
to the left of Bernie Sanders and
Alexandria Acacio Cortez he'll I'm to
the left of Bernie Sanders and
Alexandria Cascio Cortez and I have
friends who scare me with how far left
they are and then they're people even
further to the left of them and we're
talking about a very small minority
light like a very small group of people
who are true communists you know sees
the means of production communist Bernie
Sanders and Alexandria Acacio Cortez are
not bad in any way imaginable I describe
Bernie Sanders socialism as post office
socialism right it's as innocuous as the
post office or our fire fire department
socialism it's since sent simply
gathering taxes and doing a social good
with them ooh socialism and so you know
I put all of that in context because I
want you to understand the game that is
constantly being played on Americans
Republicans and conservatives in
particular like to play this game that
anything anything whatsoever that does
not capitulate to the free markets by
the way they're never they are not free
markets but that's what they like to say
so we'll use their terminology just
because anything that does not
capitulate to what Republicans call the
free market is socialism to them the
post office should be privatized right
to them every aspect of our lives should
be privatized the policing agencies
should be privatized right and they
already have private prisons right
for-profit right they believe that the
fire department should be privatized all
roads in our infrastructure should be
privatized so what they're looking for
is some extreme version of laissez-faire
capitalism that that really expect takes
all of the government resources what my
friend Randy Rhoads always said I
believe she coined it first right you
privatize the profit
and socialize the losses they want to
take taxes from the government and use
that to create this this utopia of free
markets and and then turn around if they
lose anything get that loss socialized
like the bailout so there they are for
socialism
they're just for socialism for the rich
I believe Bernie Sanders said that
phrase most popularly and most recently
but we're not talking about real
socialism we're not talking about
communism we're talking about taking
taxes and building a better
infrastructure we're talking about
taking taxes and ensuring that people
have the opportunity to work we're
talking about taking taxes and making
sure that everyone has an opportunity to
go to college without getting in some
type of obscene debt we're talking about
taking taxes and making sure that our
health care industry does not break the
backs of people who get sick and not
only do you have to compound the fact
that you're sick but now you're going
bankrupt that is not this terrifying
form of socialism that is post office
land milquetoast really easy to pallet
its FDR style socialism it is FDR style
it is it is yet another way to be quite
honest with you to put a bandaid on
capitalism so in a lot of ways
conservatives should be embracing Bernie
Sanders and Alexandre Cortez Acacio
Cortez because their version of
socialism is really what's going to save
capitalism from itself
and if they are afraid of Bernie Sanders
and aoc then who I've got some friends
to introduce you to that it really scare
you